first it was announced that Michael B
Jordan would be joining the fictional
nation of Wakanda and now John boyega
which other work and ins is Hollywood
hiding I'm Simon and this is your fake
African nation news update while the
Marvel Studios debut of spider-man got
much of the attention during the
build-up to Captain America Civil War
the first appearance of Black Panther
has since proved just as impressive
Creed director Ryan Coogler is on board
to helm the standalone Black Panther
movie which would start Chadwick Boseman
as the super-powered king of Wakanda it
has now been rumored that star wars
force awakens star John boyega may be
joining the cast as well according to
heroic Hollywood boy Yaeger is in talks
to play a role in the movie if boy
Yeager does score a part in Black
Panther he will join his fellow force
awakens actor Lupita Nyong'o as well as
Crede star Michael B Jordan earlier this
week koogler explained that the movie
would be his most personal film he told
Fast Company I'm obsessed with this
character and this story right now and I
think it's going to be very unique and
still fit into the overall narrative the
Marvel are establishing Black Panther is
set for release on july six 2018 did
Black Panther deliver and civil war or
are you pining for more pink panther let
me know in the comments or come find me
on twitter i'm at the jagan or thanks
for watching and for your entertainment
news keep it gamespot
you